but what Gregg was beginning to see was
that if the students themselves were
saying you can't say that stop her from
saying that we need rules to stop him
from saying that and that's what was new
I am nickel SP with reason TV today
we're talking with John Hite is a social
psychologist at the NYU Stern School of
Business John thanks for talking to it
my pleasure
you have obviously have a fantastic
academic reputation which precedes
anything we're doing here but also along
with Greg Luciana the co-director cuz
the director of fire fiendish for
individual rights and education a couple
of years ago you're at the coddling of
the American mind which really brought a
lot of the issues you're interested in
to a much broader audience let's talk
about campus PC and where it comes from
because this is the world we live in it
helped empowered Donald Trump he ran for
president saying I was against PC what
define and kind of quantify how we know
that political correctness is getting
bigger or worse on college campuses that
speech is actually being shut down
thought is being shut down man so it's
hard to find it so this is all so new
there's been I believe a kind of a moral
revolution a new moral culture emerging
on campus but it really is only in the
last two years so if any of your viewers
graduated from college in 2013 they
probably haven't seen it so there was a
kind of a culture we can talk about in a
moment but it's organized around around
victims of oppression it's a it's a
vertical metaphor of privileged and
oppressor people and and victims and
this idea that everything is power you
know it goes back a long way I mean
students are always at risk of being
told everything of power know everything
is money know everything is sex so we've
had these you know one-dimensional moral
cultures for a long time but they were
limited to certain departments on campus
at certain schools but something began
happening in 2014-2015 where we started
hearing all these stories when Greg and
I wrote the article it was just there
were all these amazing shocking
taury what's an example of what you know
once we tell in the paper that every we
have Jeanne sook at Harvard wrote about
how in her law school classes students
wouldn't let her they were soon for
objecting her staying violated like that
violated the law because violation well
that could trigger a sort of rape and we
can't let a student who's been raped
think about rape and so you know while
there's a certain logic to that it also
and this was the point of the article
the more you teach people to think that
way that hearing a trigger will
reactivate you're actually hurting than
when you do that so we're finding more
and more professor saying wait I'm doing
just what I've always done but suddenly
the students are freaking out and
they're reporting me to the Dean so when
we wrote the article it was all just
anecdotes right but that was in August
of 2015 that was before the big blowup
it was really in the fall of 2015 you
get the Missouri protests and then
especially Yale run so again it's after
the Yale protests that everything really
spread and that was that was like 13 or
14 months ago we had that in the Yale
video there was a good I guess a go
Nicholas Christakis yeah but I mean just
that primal scene really of where a
student is saying this is not an
intellectual space this is a safe space
or something along those lines so that
you have this tired ignominy
paradigmatic example of somebody at one
of the you know considered one of the
best colleges in the in the country
shockingly given what's going on there
but you know like hey you know you know
get out of my mind here this is pretty
stunning so so there isn't there isn't
really way to quantify other than to say
this stuff seems to be going on more ya
within a year I'm sure there will be
certain actually you know what we are
creating a survey at heterodox Academy
it's a collection we have four hundred
professors have signed on to say that we
think that we need viewpoints we think
that no university should be politically
homogeneous we're creating a bunch of
product that we think will help address
these problems and the first thing we
need is good data that were mostly
social scientists so we're creating
something called
peerless speech index it's a simple
survey you've come to our site you get
your own link you send it out and you
can find out who is afraid of speaking
openly well on what topics and why is it
because you're afraid the professor will
retaliate or because other students will
so we're just pilot testing it now but
by April we should have it up on the
website so anybody who wants to do a
survey at your own school go to
heterodox Academy org you'll find a link
and then you'll find out you know maybe
it's that though you know them for
example the men what I'm finding on my
talk the men are often very quiet during
my talk they don't ask questions they
just sit there but afterwards they come
up to me like they were you know abused
spouses or something because it's some
schools the men feel as though they
can't speak and then they go vote for
Trump so you know let's take it back a
little bit and talk about the causes you
know first off is this in a lot of the
examples you use from the Atlantic
article and I'm sure in your forthcoming
book it seems to be driven by students
yes in other cases it's driven by
professors sometimes it's administrators
you know with residents life has become
a bigger and bigger part of many people
college experience and they have all
sorts of speech and behavior codes but
if we go back a couple of decades
because the term political correctness
kind of first burst on to the
consciousness in the very late 80s or
early 90s there was a New York magazine
story talking about it I went to I went
to both undergrad and grad school in the
early 90s and I felt like I saw a shift
between that when I graduated college as
an undergrad in 85 and when I finished
grad school around 93 things have become
exactly the same thing for me so I mean
things have become more restricted in
the sense that there was a political
code or that that and I was in
literature literary than cultural
studies so it's already politicized but
that only certain viewpoints were
accessible that's right and it was kind
of the teachers saying that you know
they might have the token weird of like
okay Gillespie you're you're going to
say Frederick Douglass actually like
wage-labour
I would but he didn't know he didn't
know the beauty of social
you know or something but what is the
connection is there any kind of straight
length connection between that earlier
form and what we're seeing that the way
I think about it is that there's like
all these fuses coming together and each
one was burning separately to some
extent they all intersect it in the fall
of 2015 and so one of them is academic
trends the professorial the professorial
has leaned left in most fields for a
long time but only lean left we have
here's where we do have good data it's
it from the early 90s to the late 90s is
the big shift it's as the greatest
generation retires there are a lot of
Republicans in that generation whereas
the baby boomers men even came rushing
to the Academy either to avoid the
Vietnam War or to study racism so it's
in the 90s that the Academy goes from
leaning left to being very loud with the
only left so you lose diversity there
and that's also part of why you get this
faculty-driven
wave of PC in the early 90s I would also
if I can answer that
just na and I don't know how far his
influence extended outside of literary
and cultural studies although I said a
lot in sociology and history Michel
Foucault when you mentioned everything
is powering and I think he actually is
very proto libertarian and many of his
discussions that you know that's a
different story but there was no
question we were all through coldians
and - we were trained - and look at what
what does this say about power whatever
the checks whatever the area of subject
so I think that's exactly right there
are again it's all these fuses coming
together and so one is a sort of it's a
separate evolutionary process of ideas
about power privilege and oppression and
that meets up with an excellent
humanities ideas from psychology about
trauma bullying abuse the idea of
microaggressions was invented by a
psychologist so you get these Foucault
liened ideas you get these psychological
victimhood ideas coming together who
came up with the micrograph well the the
term goes back to the 70s or 80s but
it's popularized in an article in the
American psychologist in 2007 and is
named as a Dewald who's seeing that the
momentum so that
then the idea gets picked up so you've
got this intellectual development the
big surprise the thing that people were
not expecting was that the students are
the ones who are demanding it now this
is what took me and Greg took bread by
surprise because Greg had been fighting
all these speech roads all these things
imposed by administrators and faculty
and the students had always generally
wanted more freedom Road yeah but what
Greg was beginning to see was that if
the students themselves were saying you
can't say that stop her from saying that
we need rules to stop him from saying
that and that's what was new yeah he
mentioned I guess it was at Emory
College a case where somebody had
chalked on the sidewalk which legend
yeah and that what struck him as
particularly disturbing that that was
was students calling for the
investigation and the suppression of
speech and for him that was kind of a
Rubicon that he's very uncomfortable has
been Crum that's right the key term here
is moral dependency the most interesting
idea I've come across and easier
studying it is the idea of victimhood
culture there's a great paper by two
sociologists Manning and Campbell if you
go to head Rock Academy org type in
victimhood you can find our abbreviated
version they they analyzed how many
cultures used to be honor cultures where
a small insult must be attended to by
you you can't go get someone to fight
your battles for you you have your honor
and we move to a dignity culture as you
get more trade you don't need the honor
culture anymore in a Disney culture
sticks and stones will break my bones
names will never harm me I'm not going
to make a big deal out of a little thing
I'm just in this minute ignore you and
that is a great way to have diversity if
you have a diverse community boy do you
want a dignity culture because then the
little misunderstandings people overlook
them but what they show is that in some
universities and this is their writing
in 2014 before the blow-up in some
universities those that are most
egalitarian so it's only the most
left-leaning universities with already
gala terian and there's an authority who
can be brought in to punish decide
everybody is desperately trying to get
prestige by either showing what a victim
they are
or by punishing people who they think
have harmed victims by getting the
administration to come in so everybody
is pitching to the powers-that-be to
come in where did this come from in the
80s and 90s America changed is parenting
kids lost unsupervised time because
these have a lot of unsupervised time
yet the fights you work it out but
because of the fear of child abduction
because of the anti-bullying policies
American child-rearing change so there's
always an adult and you don't always
solve the problem and the whole point is
you want to state your case to get the
adult to punish him and not to not to
let him get the adult to punish me and
so kids haven't had the chance to learn
to deal with insults to learn to be
excluded I mean we all get excluded you
want to do so so now are you is this
turning back or is this putting on a new
dress on kind of like the mom is a
movement of the 40s or 50s or you know
you know if for pride it all goes back
to the parents particularly the mother
it seems what you know how how do you
kind of make that statement or how do
you validate that night when I think
I've you know I have two two sons 15 and
23 and my ex-wife and I often talked
about how they they started being put in
institutional situations where there was
always an adult present and not like oh
this lady is going to be in the
neighborhood so then you get run over by
a car she might hear it but you're
taking them to a place you drop them off
you sign them in there's you know what
and that's very strange and it's
different than the childhood that I had
certainly but does that you know does it
create a social type then and is that
social type is it capable of either
being reformed or it doesn't mean that
kids will grow out of it maybe not at
college but then in the workplace or in
the third day yeah so right people are
concerned about this for generations and
I think there's no question that life
and childhood has gotten more feminized
away from the masculine virtues and in
many ways that's good you know I mean
there was a lot of bullying and
name-calling and so you know to have a
general trend that way is probably right
and good in a narrow
but I think it can go too far when it
encourages moral dependency Freud was
wrong that everything goes back to the
mothers and kids relationships to their
parents matter for attachment when
they're very young but when they're in
middle school and Beyond the total
obsession is the peer group kids have to
fit into a peer group so if these norms
are peer group wise and we should bring
in social media
take whatever tribalism group business
virtue fiddling take all the things that
people always done gives 13 year-olds
Facebook beginning in 2006 and they're
you know you're really ramping up the
you know there's the mob punishment the
fear of saying something wrong so the
kids who entered college so Facebook
open this policy in twenty six twenty
two thousand six the very first kids
who've been on Facebook since thirteen
only graduate in two thousand fourteen
so professors have been encountering
these kids who are just really different
because they were used to who were born
before 1980 and that I think parts one
of the threads all these threats and
there's he knows this is not a mono
causal explanation or eight you know
what do you feel our students do
students see themselves and this goes
back to the question of kind of a victim
culture do you think that and I realized
says a typical student is if there is
one but do they see themselves more as
individuals say that when you and I were
growing up because you know I always
kind of felt like I was an individual
and the kids that my for my kids their
friends they seemed very individual and
you know I realized these are
ridiculously small samples or examples
but two kids you know do they feel less
individualized in that out of culture
that I can't add no idea how they feel
about this I think rather what we can
say is that they have been exposed
they've been raised in a moral world
that has different pillars than ours
so you and I was born in 1963 I presume
you wrote yes we were we were raised by
people who either fought World War two
or at least remember it
we were raised during the Cold War we
were raised to think that liberty and
freedom were really really important
concepts and boy they really worked it
was the free world and the not free
world it was really clear liberty
matters and it was American like we are
the pioneers and what I'm noticing is
that now and after I can show you date
on this you just do a you know Google
Trends search diversity and inclusion is
going up and up and up that phrase is
becoming very very prominent and
actually even multiculturalism is going
down so diversity inclusion is becoming
primary our kids have been raised with
such anti-bullying training know you
know if it's Valentine's Day everyone
has to get a belt we can't have anyone
be excluded so our kids have been raised
where liberty and freedom are not really
talked about like even china isn't you
know a slave comments those Liberty
doesn't matter as much diverse and
inclusion is much much more importantly
ever and the diversity doesn't extend to
say hey you know what we're all
different you know so it's not glass
Iverson it yeah it's it's three to six
to specific with meaning my diversity so
how do you address that then I guess I
have to two final questions I'm
interested in one is how do you address
that kind of and it's beyond parenting
it's kind of a set of social norms and
social cues but then also specifically
at the college level
how has the changing function of college
affected all of this because you know
it's one thing if you're going to
college in in order to get a job if
you're going to college to finish your
education so that you can be an informed
citizen or if it's you know it's like a
fancy etiquette school thing but it's so
I mean how do you address this push on
diversity and inclusion in a way that of
course doesn't mean okay now we can
finally stop kicking certain groups out
of college or anything like that but how
do we change that in a positive way sure
well so first it's important to realize
that this is not happening at most
colleges any college at which students
come to campus take class and go home
you don't get this because they're
living in multiple moral world
if people are different ages you don't
get this this is only at four-year
residential schools where there's a
moral world that emerges as these
students books of Coach against the kids
being shipwrecked and in what's the we
already Lord of the flour to the finest
yep yeah it's Gilligan's Island that's
right except for a line shot by absolute
Spurs well yeah it's Gilligan's Island
or Lord of the Flies but with a gigantic
staff of therapists and unions around to
agree so that everybody plays nice Road
so it's only the elite school and so
what do you do well I think need to
rethink the way that we do diversity
training I think the way that it's often
done given that the evidence suggests
diversity training either doesn't work
or can backfire if it's done with
hostility through I think we need to
recognize that as a country we are in
big trouble we face an existential
threat of coming apart and this is now
obvious to everybody and I think that we
need to rethink diversity training if
you're going to have a multi-ethnic
multiracial democracy you you have to
get everything right you have to look at
the centrifugal forces blowing a
founding a triple forces pulling us
together so just this morning Kara's
foster gave a great talk on on how she
does diversity training she uses humor
you've got it you got it get people to
be a little lighter and give people the
benefit of the doubt recognize that
diversity is difficult and recognize
that political diversity is every year
for decades political diversity is a
bigger divide and actually racial you
know with making progress on race gender
and sexual orientation so a lot of
things have been focusing on I mean
fortunately we're making progress using
the political divide is now I believe
the one that's going to do within and I
think it actually might do within I
think terrible things can happen and so
that I mean it helps both explain why
Trump was elected and and it's not that
Trump is if the only thing but that you
had Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump who
were kind of like equal and opposite
versions of themselves they were very
disliked it was quite equal but oh yeah
oh god but my lady dinner on Trump dia
was much further
we've ever had but at many analysts I've
read spoken to agree Trump is very much
a symptom of what was happening could
not have come in how do we not have such
dysfunction animosity distrust
romanticism and then Trump is making
those worse by violating what were the
norm so we are in big trouble and we
will still be in big trouble
once Trump leaves so I think we need to
rethink this and I think a lot of ideas
from sort of mid to late 20th century
America richard rorty's ideas have been
kicking around Arthur Schlesinger about
having having a common in group identity
a shared identity I mean this is basic
social psychology the more you emphasize
differences the more you drive people
apart but if in a weird way then is
Trump kind of doing that because he's
defining he's worried this is what is
American and it's like hey sorry that
means Mexicans early so legal ones
you're not I love you when you're here I
mean in this is the negative I mean for
me I see red whenever I hear slash into
your name because I don't like consensus
anything but you know in terms of a
common identity and if you go back to
the 1920s which was the last time where
the u.s. started to shut down mass
persistent immigration that took place
over decades it was done specifically by
defining the American as a non-immigrant
you know that's right so there's an
active discussion now about nationalism
and patriotism and before Trump was
elected back when we all thought Hillary
was going to win I wrote two essays
earlier this year on nationalism that
how the what we're seeing around the
world now is the left-right divide has
become the nationalist that left is the
globalist versus a national road so this
is very much in Europe it's in a number
of literature and I've been trying to
say because the Left hints to reject
nationalism reject patriotism reject
borders that this is a losing path
you're not going to win elections you
can't even run a country like that I've
been trying to define healthy positive
forms of nationalism Patriots it wrote
in for America it should be easy because
it's not racial at all so America should
be really good at doing this Britain
should be pretty good too and then
comes along and the first thing you said
in his inaugural address is this like
ugly blood with the blood and soil
patriotism yeah I was hoping that he was
going to say something like you know
I've said a lot of things about illegal
immigration in this country but boy if
you came here legally and you're a
citizen and you're Mexican I love you
I'm your press
I was hoping he's going to say that he
caught up but now he's made just that
he's making you know PC is his issue and
it harder for me to criticize PC now
he's made patriots in his issue which
makes me feel like you've got your
number idea he must be hacking your
computer so we'll talk a little bit
about college and you know how has you
know College has changed in the 200 or
so years it's really been around in the
US and it became fully became a mass
phenomenon around 1970 that's when a
majority of high school seniors went on
to some form of college we we here now
partly because it's so expensive that
the stakes are high in college and that
you know that clearly puts anxiety on
parents on students on professors there
are fewer and fewer tenure-track lines
that the business models at school how
does that affect the campus climate and
particularly the issues that you think
about and what needs to be adjusted
there yeah I'm not sure that it affects
the campus climate so much right now but
I think it's likely to lead to a huge
disruption at some point in the next 10
15 years so you know if you go back you
know five years before any of this the
intense you know TC stuff was happening
once MOOC started coming out and the
cost of college was such an issue a lot
of people are saying it's just a matter
of time before there's a big disruption
if college is not delivering the value
if there are alternatives it's just a
matter of time before most schools go
out of business
Harvard and Yale Chicago and they'll
always be there but most schools will go
out of business and I think what's
happened is as College has gotten
weirder and weirder and all this bad
publicity most people in the country
look at the coddling culture they look
at the students protesting they're not
sympathetic many of them are horrified
so I think that's a black mark on
colleges and what are they doing to deal
with it a lot of the things that the
elite schools are doing to deal with the
protests are hiring a lot more
administrators and a lot more expensive
program so I think they're kind of
digging their own grave a little faster
they're speeding up the time of
interruption as soon as someone can come
up with a way of actually training or
certifying people so that they can
actually get jobs
I mean colleges are going to face a big
loss of market share well and it'll be a
shame too because I mean the liberal
arts have always and particularly the
humanities have always been kind of
suspect and those are really in a lot of
ways that those are the types of areas
of course areas as well as frames of
mind that would actually help us
navigate a more diverse a tolerant
society the best way pomf that's right
it's sort of the classical things that
we say the classic as you say about the
liberal arts and liberal arts education
are just what we need now you know
unfortunately my wife went to Smith is
neither grad she loved it she loved
literature so she went to university
Virginia to get a master's degree
thinking that she loves literature lingo
very literature and she was so
disappointed because it was written more
about politics and power and Foucault
and it wasn't do it wasn't about the
Richard wasn't liberal arts thinking
very ideological yeah so you know I
think the humanities it kind of lost
credit and I think it's their own fault
we will in total agreement and we will
leave it there thank you we've been
talking about Jonathan Hite he is a
social psychologist at New York
University's Stern School of Business
and he's the foremost thinker about the
coddling of the American mind and what
we need to do to address it John thanks
so much Nick my pleasure four reason TV
I'm Nicholas
[Music]